I lost 20 pounds this winter from going vegan, but can't put weight back on.
I feel like my metabolism is on hyperdrive, and that I have catexia. Is there a way to
reverse this and gain weight and muscle? I'm sticking to the diet who gave me an eating as
much and as often as possible. Well, the definition of catexia is that you're losing
three to four pounds a week, or two to four pounds a week, no matter what you're doing.
You're not trying to lose weight and you just can't stop losing weight. So if you're
like, well, I'm not losing any more weight, but I can't gain it back. The question
is, are you under weight? Yes, I am under weight. I really need to gain 20 pounds back.
Well, we do, if you go to this right here and you type in catexia, I have information
on catexia and some different hints that you could do. And you could do that even if you
don't take one or do I have catexia? Well, who cares about the definition? If you need
to gain weight, go back and look at that video on catexia and some of the hints that I give
on that, that will help.